okay would you rather get caught  masturbating or [ __ ] your pants in  public i think i would rather get uh  caught masturbating [ __ ] in public  is is pretty that's a pretty bad  situation end up on a list if you get  caught masturbating in public yeah but i  mean  it's embarrassing but you're not a  [ __ ] sex offender they got us on that  list already dude i mean they know yeah  i mean i got an email threatening me the  other day did you ever get that email  where they say we have you masturbating  and they show you the phone number and  they say don't contact us we'll contact  you and i was like [ __ ] it's the  funny thing because they're contacting  someone i don't care dude i don't care  they're like oh we know what you were  masturbating too it's like i talked  about it on a podcast good luck i hope  you enjoyed it man because  good my wife knows i masturbate i mean  everyone at this point that's like the  least controversial thing that could  happen